[Music]
hi everyone thanks for coming to our
talk today I'm building apps for the
Chrome OS ecosystem my name is sweet and
I'm a product manager for Android apps
on Chrome OS for today's session we're
going to cover three different topics
the first is an update on our Chrome OS
ecosystem growth the second we're going
to be introducing the cool new features
that we've been working on
and lastly developer notes and best
practices to enhance your experience on
Chrome OS so starting off with our
ecosystem update for Chrome OS growth
Chrome OS devices run Android apps
through the Play Store using an Android
container but we are inherently
different from a lot of the traditional
Android phones in that we have a larger
screen we also have different inputs
including keyboard mouse stylus users
also use more multi-monitor support with
us and they tend to use a lot more of
multitasking
with multiple windows and activities
going on at the same time so as a
leading OS for Google's large screen
experiences we've been really doubling
down to provide a hardware that's
capable of doing all these wonderful
things in addition to the clam shells
the convertibles and the chrome boxes
this past year we've launched our very
first tablets and detachable but as we
have more of a device Hardware corpus
we've also seen more users as well in q4
of 2018 21% of all notebooks sold in the
US were Chromebooks
that's a 23 percent year-over-year
growth over last year we're currently in
9 countries and physically in more than
10,000 stores and we're continuing that
expansion this year as well
so we have our device portfolio we have
more users but also users are responding
more to apps and Google Chrome OS in the
last year app usage on Android on Chrome
OS has grown by 4x and that's a
testament to our growing app catalog
along with users finding more utility
and better experiences on their Chrome
OS devices from the apps there's two
that I really want to highlight the
first one is asphalt 8 a racing car game
we work with them to really enhance the
experience on our Chrome OS devices
specifically around keyboard support and
tablet mode and we found that after
these improvements they've seen a 6x
boost in daily activity and a 9x boost
in-app revenue we've been really proud
of these numbers and we've been working
with them on asphalt 9 which is in our
retail mode in physical stores as well
to show off the other app is concepts
which we just saw in our video just now
concepts is an illustrating app and it's
really well positioned with Chrome OS
because we have a really fast and
responsive stylus along with a larger
screen real estate on our devices so
users can ID anymore compared to the
other devices we've seen that on Chrome
OS they've had 12x more time spent and
double the paid conversions and on our
higher end devices for the picks of
books and pixel slates it's even better
with 20x more time spent and quadruple
the paid conversions and those are just
two examples of apps that we've been
working with with our developers and
they've seen users embrace them and
we're happy to work with you as well to
promote and really make your apps shine
on Chrome OS as an added bonus your apps
improve for Chrome OS are also going to
benefit from those on Android photo both
phones and Android tablets so you get
more bang for your buck too
next I'm going to turn it over to Stefan
kun a whenever Ang Lee's on what we've
been working on this past year
hello everyone I'm Sivan Cunha I'm one
of the tech leads bringing Android to
Chrome OS and you have maybe seen me
earlier in earlier talks and this brings
me already to what I'm are talking about
today well all the changes we have done
over the past year to this year so let's
have a look first off we be launching
android pi well it's a little bit snow
of yesterday I know but the thing is
like we were actually starting that
conversion process end of last year with
our pixel slate tablet and we are
continuing to rolling out hi to all our
fleet and at the same time we are also
improving the quality stability
performance and all the other kind of
things over the course of this year at
the same time we were also turning on
Android P by default on for most users
so means for end users okay
so another thing what we have done is we
were doubling down on improving the
developer quality so first of the s of
one-click installer for Android studio
much less hassle than before you will
definitely agree on that one we improved
also the linting support which basically
gives you some kind of highlights where
you are doing something which is
possibly not yet ideal for Chrome OS so
basically everything what we tell you is
beneficial for the phone as well as for
the for Chrome OS but in this particular
case it's of course especially for that
another thing what we were doing is
inside the Android know inside the Linux
VM we were adding audio support which
basically means you are getting all the
audio tools which we are used to use on
Linux directly on the system which means
audacity and all these kind of things
are working so in for the next thing I'm
calling to Emily who is actually
demonstrating how to improve well how we
have actually used ADB now over USB
thanks Jeff on so I'm super happy to
announce what we've added here can we
bump over to the computer so here I have
Android studio running on the pixel book
oops and I could run uh-oh what have I
done
aha okay well I run the app
and it pushed it directly to the device
this is last year's news if you're here
last year so there's nothing that new
with that but what is new and this does
not require developer mode so super
exciting I got pixel to phone I can plug
it in over USB and this time actually
let's do a profiling just so you know
that I'm legit here in the bottom you
see this connect to Linux so allow Linux
to access my USB device and if the demo
gods smiled and they have smiled on me
Google pixel to excel is right there so
I can select the phone this will
hopefully run my profiler there we go
the app is hopefully working please
installing apks oops my screen has
fallen asleep
so there's the app running you can see
the profiling it's legit yeah you can
clap yeah thank you Stefan in your team
and you can see it by clock you get the
screen you know you get the screen tops
you can dig into the memory just like
you'd expect in profiling what can I say
thanks a lot I'll be back don't worry
back to you Stefan Oh something was many
thanks Emily ok so another thing we know
that you are actually one of the power
users of our system because you have an
IDE you have Android applications you
have Chrome all these other kind of
things and one of the things what you're
really missing is a virtual desktop so
beginning with m76 which is currently in
in our canary channel you can already
test out this feature simply go into
Chrome's flex and turn it on another
thing what we were doing is well in the
past HDCP was not really supported on
external monitor we have mitigated that
you can now playback videos on external
screen if you ever plan to actually use
for example surface view set secure well
be aware there are monitors which are
not supporting this and it's of course a
very bad experience for the user if he
sees only a black box and set of buttons
and cannot press anything so therefore
don't really use it if it don't really
mean to use it another thing what we
were doing is integration so a lot of
integration work was going for example
into a our core which is in all our
tablets which have both facing cameras
it's being used already in schools for
things like geogebra and google
expedition and many more to follow
another thing what we were doing is
instant app support in snap support is
ready to roll out and if your
application is doing this you will
actually see that very shortly I oh I
have seen this somewhere well this is
meant to be exactly as mint input and
output so we have done various things
around i/o one of them is bringing some
drives any kind of external media to
Chromebooks so when you plug it in the
Android application will be able to
access it directly so that was one of
the big asks from last year
another thing is play fires so this is
something which is if you ever use the
Chrome or as files browser you have
possibly seen that there was no way of
accessing the Android files if you want
to send something or inspect something
well now inside this tool you have
actually also play files which is the
mirror of SD card so you can get to all
these files another thing is if you have
documents provider API like for example
Google Drive Dropbox or anything like
that they will actually be reflected now
also in the files application so
basically this is fully transparent and
it's running inside chrome space but
it's using all the Android features on
that point so you can drag and drop
files now from all these cloud storage
providers without anything thinking
about that and if you have if you're
using this cloud provider API for your
own applications you can even then make
it that you can actually use this
directly so like editing our files and
so on manage devices we head there also
several new add-on so first off we were
improving the installation speed four
minutes two seconds and it's also much
more secure so as therefore it should be
now really be installed when an
administrator is asking for it another
thing what we were doing is when you are
using the VPN connection from Chrome OS
then Android will automatically use the
same VPN connection which is a huge
improvement in regards of security so
now I'm coming to the most important
thing for you because this is a section
which is explicitly trying to target all
the things where you should actually
watch out for to make your application
shine on Chrome OS so let's have a look
multi-monitor this is not really new
right we're talking about this one
already last year but one of the things
what we were silently doing behind the
day behind the scenes was we were doing
a lot of scaling because the thing is if
you have an internal small monitor which
is 4k and you have an external big
screen which is maybe even also 4k then
there is an a size differential of two
to one which basically means if you are
dragging a window from A to B
suddenly it becomes like a giant mess so
and therefore that is something what the
user doesn't really want to see so
therefore what we do is we scaled that
sink down to match the same size as on
the on the notebook but the problem with
that is of course that well scaling
means like you are losing some some
information from the thing it's getting
blurry it's not really that great so and
therefore what we are trying to do going
forward this we will actually change the
density on the on the fly that is
something what we were talking about
last year and the year before about
changing the size so this is now the
next thing which is the next and the
last thing that we are asking anything
from you is to actually make your
application be aware of different
densities on an activity level so don't
do that into inside your service or what
not do it actually inside the activity
because you might actually move to a
Windows on the screen and you never know
where this right so and because that if
you're using on configuration changes
check out the density and otherwise
listen to these kind of events
so gaming if you were ever using gaming
and you were using a game controller you
have possibly noticed that there is not
really much of what Android is doing so
you cannot really figure out how many
controllers are connected and if the
mapping was wrong it didn't really work
we are changing this basically very soon
you will actually have the standard API
which is on any phone so if you want to
test it out test it on your phone if
it's working there it'll work in the
future well then say its relative mouse
positioning which is used by all kinds
of first-person shooters and whatnot we
have that also now supported which went
out in m74 which is now and file well in
in in release state so you can request
the pointer and you can actually listen
then to all changes and go for that so
and with that I'm coming to the most
important topic of this talk which is
animation junk well if you were ever
doing any kind of animations you have
possibly seen kind some kind of jank
what is jank it's something like when
something moves very slowly suddenly you
see this kind of hiccup when something
is like stuck and then continuing so and
there is unfortunately no tool after now
which shows you where this hiccup is
coming from but we were working on that
very hard so
and for that I have a small presentation
for that so unfortunately this is not
that easy there are a lot of boxes but
don't be scared if you have never seen
them before
I will actually get used to ever say so
first off when you look into a standard
application it is usually using double
buffering what does double buffering
means it means you have one buffer which
is being shown and one buffer which is
being rendered - and you are constantly
iterating between the two of them and
this application is basically it's
getting the buffer it's rendering to the
buffer and it's submitting the buffer to
be displayed and then it's doing the
same thing again and over and over and
over again it's always exactly the same
thing and in screen space you see then
first the old picture then comes a
vision which is basically the end of the
scan out of the buffer which means like
at which point in time you can flip to
the next one and then it flips to the
next frame this is the ideal state so
looking deeper into the system this
driver space so in driver space we are
waiting now for the visa ring from the
previous frame so that we can take the
buffer and render stuff into it so which
is basically then producing all the buff
master DMA commands and putting them
into one contiguous buffer so that the
GPU can read them and continuing the
same thing and in GPU space the GPU is
simply like taking that thing it's
executing these buffers which were being
produced by the driver space and doing
that one by one and flipping it
automatically via Hardware event into
view as soon as I just need it so where
comes change now and play well Jeng
comes if for example the rendering takes
much longer than you expect so and in
that case what happens well basically
you're repeating the previous frame and
inverse whatever you have already queued
up in order to be rendered is possibly
producing the next frame which is also
bad so it's not only one frame which is
bad it's two or three so therefore it's
really a bad thing to have that so
another thing what can happen is that in
user space you would actually see
something similar so which means like
for example there is memory swapping
involved chrome is basically loading
some new notifications or maybe Android
is doing some compaction or whatnot and
in that case you might actually end up
in the same state so but unfortunately
we are running a desktop operating
system right which is not only that
so now it's getting a little bit more
complicated because we have suddenly
multiple clients which have to be
rendered so we have now n things which
are being rendering at the same time so
think about everything what I was
talking before but only n times so in
this case 2 and we haven't driver space
exactly as many boxes again only doubled
and well GPU space gets crammed right
because we have to do now multiple
things which are obviously realized and
well then comes the scary thing which is
a compositor what is the compositor well
basically it's now taking all these
surfaces and it's compositing them
together into one surface which means
like we have to read everything again
write it again into Z output buffer
which is another overhead right so let's
complete the picture with some more
boxes from what happened before and now
if you look into the screen and you look
from the upper left to the lower right
you see that blue things percolating
through the system all the way to the
output except for there is no blue slide
on the screen right which means we have
already created a pipeline here a
pipeline is a good thing in some ways
because the thing is like if the system
has some fluctuations like memory
swapping or whatnot you can compensate
for them but the thing is it has also
the problem that if you click something
it might actually take a little bit of
time additional time to actually see
that so the good news is there is
actually very old technology from the
90s which is actually trying to
eliminate this by using overlays so
overlays is basically the GPUs and
reading out two buffers at the same time
it's blending them together but
unfortunately that works only as long as
you're not su mning in or not you are
you're not turning your display into
portrait for example so and since most
users are possibly playing around with a
zoom level it might actually not work
it's a good news on the other hand as we
are working on it by the end of the year
I hope much much earlier we will be able
to address that and you will have always
double buffering if you're running in
front so is that coming to the tool
itself so what kinds of tool do well
first off it can actually show how the
buffers are percolating through the
system it can show you when memory was
actually being swapped it can show you
how busy the CPU is the GP who is at any
point of time
it can actually show you all kinds of
things temperature speed and whatnot
from all the different components inside
the system and best of all if you have
some traces inside your code and you
want to see exactly what happened at
Voltron time you can actually put some
in there and you can actually see them
and monitor them there as well so as you
see everything in relation to each other
and then you can actually drill down and
see why you have seen junk so with that
let's come to a sort demo so let's see
let's bring up our tool so this tool is
basically it's a small particle
generator and you can see already here I
mean yeah you can so you can basically
see like the lower line is 60 frames per
second the next line is already friends
per second 15 and so on and so on
so and so in order to start the tool
what I'm doing is I'm pressing ctrl
shift G so now tool is running and they
are also aging look at that that was
fast
much faster than I expected so let's see
so first let's try to zoom out a little
bit to see the regular pattern you can
actually see now here I hope you can see
my cursor yes you can awesome
you can actually see how the buffer is
so first off we have four buffers here
so the upper line is always in the thing
what's application and/or surface
flinger sees the next line is what
chrome is seeing for its compositor and
then comes the next buffer and the next
buffer is the next Baba so there are
lots of buffers we have four buffers
means quadruple buffering so then we
have the Android compositor which is
doing a little bit of stuff before it's
actually passing it on to Chrome and
it's doing something and we see chrome
is also rendering and as you can see
there are two buffers which is basically
saying it's two using double buffering
at that point and time and looking into
the memories memory sing you can
actually see how much memory was being
used you can see a line creeping up here
which is oh look at that so memory is
actually definitely creeping up over
time and you can also then see that the
GPU was very busy here see so there is
only a little bit and there here is a
pretty solid line so let's drill in and
let's see the GL thread was taking
longer look at that okay so why was a GL
thread keep taking more time let's have
a look
there is what is this I think this is
the temperature of the system is
incredible it's 84 degrees that is
possibly always a reason why it was
actually going down because you are
starting possibly to throttle the system
at that point in time so but in general
this tool gives you all the information
in one go and you can let's call it
through you can see at the end that
there is Composition Jang somewhere so
if you want to see anything more about
this tool please come by our scent boxes
we have there actually people which we
were training to X and/or they are in
working on the tool which is which are
able to actually handle anything inside
your application if you want to see why
your application is checking please let
us know so with that back to the slides
so if you want to try it on your own m75
is going to bethe around today or
tomorrow so you can actually simply take
the beta Channel going to developer mode
unfortunately you need to develop a mode
for this because traces are of course
some kind of security risk so therefore
we need to be in developer mode for that
one so and then go into settings flags
and say that you want to use the
virtualization tool and then navigators
as page to see the result for the usage
stop on Jeng activate it at your
additional counters if you want to and
run your application and then once you
are at a point press control-shift G and
see what happens you can use W and s at
any point in time in order to zoom in
and out of the timeline last but not
least we have update or documentation so
if you go online you will actually see
that how to use the tool and we will add
more information there going forwards
and well come to our sandbox to actually
get it done is that I'm passing it on to
Emily
thanks Jeff on so I'm Emily Roberts I'm
a developer advocate working on Chrome
OS I know many of you which is really
exciting and okie-dokie so we've learned
a lot about where Chrome OS is and lots
of the new tools and features we've
brought this year I want to talk a
little bit about what you can do to
optimize your app what you can do to
make your apps look awesome and work
really awesome on Chrome OS so I'm gonna
talk a little bit about input and then
about output and I'm also gonna talk a
little bit about the slash in the middle
which is a surprise topic coming up so
your applications should support
keyboard thanks very much
have a good day just kidding if you know
me I like to talk a lot so I'm going to
talk about a few more things seriously
support keyboard input I know most
people here already do that and if you
do the code looks something like this so
if I am looking for a key up or key down
I'm looking for the J key I do what I
want to do I return true everything's
good one little gotcha that we've seen
in a few apps don't swallow every key
that the system sends so if I'm not
using a key so I'm not using any other
key but J here pass it back up to super
backup to the system for example chrome
OS might want to do something smart with
ctrl N and open a new window or ctrl
shift G like that tool we just saw and
run the graphics trace if your app is a
black hole that swallows all the key
presses then it's sad for the user or
else Chrome OS has to do some tricks so
pass it up to super some of you may have
noticed that Chrome OS keyboards have a
refresh key what the heck is up with
that it's a legitimate key it's got his
very own key code and everything key
code refresh so in the web world it
makes sense to refresh a web page but if
you think about social media apps or any
Content app there's also a refresh type
of action that users expect and if
there's a refresh key sitting in front
of your users well they're gonna expect
when they press it that your app
refreshes so you just need to handle
keep
code refresh like in the previous slide
and do the Refresh action in your app
the good news is if you're already using
swipe refresh layout this will be wired
up I don't think it's quite wired up yet
but it'll be wired up automatically for
you coming forward so you press refresh
that type of label layout will refresh
automatically oh this one's fun so if
you think about a mobile operating
system and an app optimized for that and
suddenly it's on a laptop with a
touchpad and stylus and all that stuff
it's a super interesting wonderful super
challenging problem to think about like
how does that happen it's cool that's
why I'm doing the job I'm doing a super
interesting so let's talk about touchpad
for example a user on a desktop if they
do a two finger swipe with a touchpad
they expect the app to scroll well
that's not what happens in a phone where
it's like a one finger hold and drag
type of motion so Chrome OS
automatically wires that up for you so
most of you have nothing to do a user
swipes on the touchpad and it works
that's awesome that's what we want if
you're doing something a little more
tricky with your motion events for
example if you're drawing out maybe that
scrolling motion is gonna start drawing
on the canvas is just not what you want
so all you have to do is or what works
in most cases I should say check the
button state if it's zero no buttons
being pressed it's not a drawing event
and you can just ignore it and that
should work great okie dokie so this is
a super fun game it's EA's NBA live
mobile basketball take a look at it it's
pretty fun to play on Chromebooks it's a
little janky on the screen but that's
okay so take a look at the left and take
a look at the right EA did something
really smart which is if a system is not
keeping up then it's cutting out extra
animations and that stuff so that the
actual gameplay is still going on which
is awesome but you'll notice that poor
guy on the left his basketballs trailing
along behind him like a little chihuahua
he's not really doing anything cool this
is the left is the past and the right
frame is the
in state of things it's much more
interesting the balls bouncing up and
down he's doing like cool moves that's
what we want to see so issue was
absolutely not
EAS this game is awesome in fact as I
said I think they did something really
intelligent
the issue was Chrome OS our language
skills weren't that good
we don't speak arm that well for many of
our x86 devices and so the good news is
we've gone to language school
we've diligently done our homework we
speak arm a little bit better so our
translation from arm to x86 is much
better so games will automatically get
that and there's a lot of new
improvements coming this year in the
pipeline already so if you're building
for arm good news should see some
improvements in translation you'll be
able to view those those cool moves
however if you care about performance
and who doesn't write us but especially
if you're a game or a creative app
support x86 because all of our top
applications are sorry our top devices
are x86 most of them are 64-bit the
64-bit requirements coming and don't
throw away arm 32 because obviously
there's lots of those devices too so arm
32 arm sixty-four x86 32 X eighty-six 64
sounds like a lot but it's actually
quite easy an Android studio and with
Android app bundles it bundles it up all
nicely since to the Play Store the Play
Store will only send the api's that your
users need so it doesn't increase their
download size or anything like that so
thank you very much in advance for
always supporting x86 okie dokie so
here's the talk it topic I'm really
excited about which is layout this is
the oh oh I didn't tell you the slash
was the NDK translation so input slash
indicate Oh anyway so let's talk about
layout there are mobile phones obviously
but we're moving a lot beyond that
there's tablets there's Chromebooks
there's foldables there's external
monitors there's TVs there's all sorts
of things your apps need to work across
all of those devices and that's becoming
more and more true as time goes on and
the ideal situation is one app can just
fluidly and seamlessly handle
so on a Chromebook if I'm resizing your
app just gets bigger it looks great does
what it needs to do somebody opens a
foldable it works great somebody plugs
an external monitor it works great so
this goes a long way
one approach is to use different layout
buckets based on screen sizes so I'm
sure many of you have seen this I hope
so if not you can check out our resizing
code lab in the code lab hence you have
one resource file and then different
layout buckets landscape wide landscape
wide portrait maybe you have six maybe
you have two depending on your layout
let's talk about something else which is
navigation patterns so this is how your
users experience your app how they get
around your app how they explore your
content super related to screen sizes
but I think it deserves its own separate
topic so what happens if you have a
mobile phone app and you put it on an
external monitor it might look something
like this it looks horrible it looks
terrible this is a photo viewing app and
the developer the designer should
probably be sent back to design school
should be thrown out of the building
it's me so don't throw me out yet please
give me a give me a second chance but
you can see that it's a photo viewing
app maybe on the phone fine you have 100
photos you don't want a million little
previews but come on we've got lots of
screen screen real estate we can do
better
I could literally like fit inside those
columns with my arms outstretched
there's so much wasted space and most
importantly take a look at the
navigation it's all stretched out it's
tiny can you see what is that what those
icons are I doubt it from there right
and if you're visually you know if you
have some different your lower vision
user you're a little bit farsighted
you're a normal person with perfect
eagle eye vision it's really hard to see
to understand and if you have any
mobility issues to even interact with
those touch targets thumbs down right so
I get a second chance
here's my second draft you can see I did
a little bit better
it's a photo viewer I put a little a
photo preview if I have enough space did
a little bit better in the middle and
most importantly and this is what I'm
talking about the navigation is over on
the left this is a side navigation skive
icons the labels
they're all close together it's easy to
navigate for anybody using the
navigation that github link will be live
very soon if you want to see my amazing
code for this amazing demo check it out
probably later this week or next week
and take a look at the material design
site there's lots of great things they
have a number of material studies which
are like toy apps looking at the stuff
and they're doing exactly what I'm
talking about so they're on a mobile
phone maybe they use the bottom
navigation it's a large landscape
they've got site navigation with icons
and labels and then if it's large but
not so large maybe like a rail
navigation on the left I want to take
just a second to call it a really
awesome developer we worked with this
year Adobe as they were optimizing Adobe
Acrobat for Chrome OS this year which
meant keyboard input Mouse simply drag
and drop all that other great stuff they
also redesigned their layout so it
worked really well on large screens so a
mobile phone they've got exactly the
same bottom navigation which makes sense
people are used to works but on a larger
screen moves to the side navigation so
great work Adobe thank you and I'm sure
your users thank you too you can check
out Adobe Acrobat and some of their
other apps in our sandbox 10th or for
yourself okay so this is the slide I
inserted it's a gift to you in case you
haven't dived into jetpack yet please do
as an Android developer it's made my
life so much easier thank you very much
particularly with what we're talking
about particularly all these different
screen sizes view model just makes
saving your state so much easier it's
very elegant way to handle it a
navigation makes your fragment headaches
and you're pushing and popping to the
fragments that go away so do Android
comm slash jetpack check it out I think
you'll appreciate it if you don't know
what I'm talking about so we're nearing
the end I wanted to do our call out to
our code labs we have resizing code lab
as well as optimizing code lab which is
like keyboard mouse drag and drop all
that fun stuff
they've been slightly refreshed for 2019
so check them out and what's cool in the
code lab tent is you can go onto a
Chromebook
develop on the Chromebook and Android
studio like we saw earlier and then push
it right to the device which is kind of
cool as well last but not least we have
a bunch of sand boxes all around IO so
in the Chrome OS tent in the gaming tent
in the Android tent
we're in flutter I think anyway we're
all over and you can talk with the
engineers that are building these
products we were really fortunate to get
like 40 of the engineers that work on
Chrome OS so if you have questions go
and talk to them use them try this stuff
out try lots of the great apps we have
and Linux also known as crostini on
Chromebooks is really improving so you
can go into the Chrome OS 10 and look at
developing on Chromebooks for the web
for Android game development we got
unity running which is kind of cool and
most importantly well not most
importantly least importantly check out
our cool enamel pins we have eight of
them the eighth one I think is
super-secret but we have seven that you
can go in each of the sand boxes they're
really cool collect them and with that I
think I've got no more slides left oh
yeah sorry there's my little pin that's
from the Android sandbox check it out
okie dokie so you've learned a lot about
what's going on I hope you're excited
about the new tools and hope you're
excited about the enamel pins please
think about screen sizes please think
about navigation and keyboard input
support x86 and all these things can
help us support you on the Play Store
keep in touch let us know what you're
doing we're really excited as always to
work with the developers and this great
community so thank you for building on
Chrome OS thank you for building for
Chrome OS and thanks for your time for
coming here today and spending it with
us and interacting with the sought-after
we'll be around in the sand boxes and
with that I've got to say thank you to
sweet and Stefan my fellow co-presenters
and thanks again to you talk to you soon
[Music]